hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I o
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied in taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in the course of
his famous [ __ ] mechanics book eight
distinction of three main types of
friendship of thelia Aristotle talks
about friendships that are sort of the
lowest end of that they're not
friendships in terms of who the person
is on account of virtue they're not
friendships in terms of the pleasure
that the friends provide to each other
in the course of the friendship but
rather their friendships in terms of
what we could call usefulness or utility
this is a variety of the good that
Aristotle calls in Greek toe some fair
on and we can think of this in terms of
instrumental good that the useful is
always useful as an instrument to get
something else so you know money is a
useful good par excellence because it's
actually not good for anything by itself
it's only good for what you can buy with
it you can say well has a symbolic value
sure dad also is something that resides
outside of the bits of paper or the
numbers in your ledger there's many
other things that are that are also
useful medicine is useful for health
although we don't really
join taking medicine you know dressing
up in certain ways could be something
that's useful for I'm portraying certain
certain characters or not those but
maybe we don't want to put on a button
down shirt you know all sorts of things
where they're not necessarily pleasant
but we do them or we pursue them or we
choose them because they provide us with
something else I think for a lot of
people study is like that you know when
we talk about an instrumental value to
education why should you study Aristotle
well because you can improve your
critical thinking skills there you're
saying that the the value of Aristotle
and studying it does that lie in
studying it but rather in something else
you know maybe you can get hired or do
better in your job because you've got
critical dating skills or something like
that there are subtle sense there's
nothing actually wrong with this the
useful is a kind of good it's just not
the same kind of good as the pleasant or
the noble or even the just or certain
other kinds of goods so in a friendship
of usefulness our utility that provides
the basis for the relationship between
the two people for the mutual affection
the auntie fee-based coming from the
words in return and unloving or being in
you know sort of effective relationship
with each other that's what provides
that basis so it's not that you you
don't necessarily feel anything towards
the person but you feel an on account of
what it is that you're getting from them
so you know if you don't particularly
like hanging out with your relatives but
every time that you do they give you a
you know ten dollar bill that's a great
example of a relationship of usefulness
perhaps they like having you around
maybe you're not actually useful to them
but you know they they make its pleasant
for them right but you're there because
you're getting that that useful good for
yourself there are many other
relationships like this as well a lot of
Education relay
ships are like this our relationships
that we have where we exchange something
back and forth say between neighbors can
be like that there's nothing to say that
a relationship based on that can't
develop into something more but while
it's primarily a relationship with
utility we should understand it as such
so Arizona thinks that this is actually
the easiest kind of relationship to come
by because there's so many different
ways in which people can be useful to
each other he says even rulers ended up
having and quite a few people who are
useful to them so many relationships I
think in frameworks of common tasks like
you know sailors on the same voyage
would be an example I think one that we
can probably relate to a little bit more
easily people on the same team in an
office people who are engaged in some
sort of process that they're not
particularly by an enjoyable book
perhaps remunerative or beneficial in
some other way a lot of networking I
think works like this you know we would
like to think that the people that were
networking with are actually genuinely
good people who we could get to know and
love for their own sake or are at least
pleasant to be with but sometimes
networking in malls just you know
exchanging cards and seeing whether we
can be a benefit to each other and if
you can't then nobody emails the other
person or follows up on it and they're
excited again he's not saying that this
is a bad thing this is actually a good
thing it's just not the same thing as
the other kinds of relationships I'm
common tasks coming projects come
organizations these relationships tend
to be based on some sort of necessity
they supply each other with what is is
lacking so if I you know exchange you
know the various goods and services with
another person and I keep doing that I
patronize their business I have this
sort of relationship with them if I
decide to trade it with somebody
you know maybe I teach them about
Aristotle so that then they can teach me
about martial arts or how to balance my
my books or any of those sorts of things
those are useful relationships those are
any very useful things I think it could
be based on a benefit that we confer
upon each other i scratch your back you
scratch mine will often help me put this
right or some sort of profit that we
might derive together and sometimes
these these can all be wrapped up in one
where you know if things work well we
get the benefit of the profit if things
don't work well then replaced in a state
of necessity where we're lacking
something that we need to get from
somebody else so about Aristotle says
sometimes they're these are not that
close to the connection the strictures
that he's told us about a friendship
where her friends need to spend a lot of
time with each other it's not really the
case for friendships of utility we don't
need to actually spend a lot of time
with each other either physically or
even virtually we can we can you know
interact with each other when we need to
and then not interact for for quite a
long time he says that in some cases it
might not even be pleasant or it could
actually be unpleasant these might be
people that we would not associate with
were we not getting something out of it
and were they not getting something out
of it in return or perhaps there's
pleasure involved right but we only are
thinking about getting the pleasure
later on we're not actually in the
relationship because we find the person
Pleasant or being with the person
pleasant but though they can provide us
with something that is pleasant so for
example in ancient times it was quite
common you see a lot of sat takers about
this for not only philosophers but for
many other people to try to get dinner
invitations hey and this is a big thing
in H
x impark is there was a lot of food
insecurity i think but also because you
know people who would put on dinner
parties usually had a good cook cooking
took a lot longer back then if you
wanted to enjoy special dishes or things
like that you probably needed to make
friends with somebody who's rich as a
matter of fact if you read the Havanese
Laertes you will find philosophers
giving each other a hard time about it's
at certain points on some of the
students and Socrates for example now
why is that a relationship of utility
the host is inviting the people perhaps
to get some pleasure out of them or
perhaps because it increases his or her
social status perhaps because it's as
expected it perhaps to keep the
philosopher the poet from writing bad
things about them the philosopher or the
poet or the historian whoever it is
showing up there to get a meal off and
to get a fancy meal perhaps sometimes
you know you read some of these these
stories the dinner parties were not
always great occasion sometimes you get
kind of kind of the poor fair or you
know you can seated way down there and
all the good food is way up here there's
all sorts of permutations on the city
could talk about I don't want to get to
point out of it but it illustrates what
Aristotle is talking about here a
friendship in terms of usefulness right
and you might go back over and over
again you know whenever there's a new
dinner going on right there's lots and
lots and lots of relationships that fall
into this this class now he also says
that friends the friends who are
involved in this they end the friendship
when the usefulness ends that's a
natural thing to happen the friendship
was based upon the friends being useful
to each other providing some sort of
service or benefit or necessity to each
other and when they can't provide that
to each other than they they don't
associate anymore they don't feel that
at that feeling of affection wishing
well to the other person anymore they
may not even think about them at all
they just disappear into the mass these
are also as Aristotle says
most prone to disagreements why are they
most prone to disagreements because it's
not based on you know sort of a stronger
foundations of you know really admiring
who the other person is or even being
pleasant to each other each person is
trying to get as much as they can out of
the relationship as much of the benefit
the usefulness as they can and they will
often disagree about well who is being
more useful and what should the
trade-off be and so you know these these
are prone to disagreements that can
actually break up the friendship if if
it becomes too in a pleasant or the
person ceases being useful now this is
also another important point these can
exist between good people and bad people
bad people who hang around with them
long enough they will probably end up
hurting you in some way and her is the
toblerone injury or the injurious is the
opposite of the useful but for a while
the bad people can be quite useful as a
matter of fact there may be some things
that bad people tend to be more useful
for then good people although that's
been a whole different topic but this
kind of friendship can exist really
between anybody it's the lowest form of
friendship if this is all that a person
has in their life aerosol the things
that they're kind of missing out because
friendship itself is a good thing but
it's still better than nothing and it's
very important in the workings not only
of our economy but even our households
our neighborhoods all sorts of other
things that our workplaces on great
example all sorts of other contexts as
well so this is that particular form of
friendship